Nikhil: From calorie
down to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Lay's chips in
the US and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
Here are all the Lay's
chips you'll find in India
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the Lay's chips in the US
you can't find in India.
Oh, my good God. Yeah!
To begin things, I'm
going to go with the one
I hate the most, Spanish tomato tango.
Yeah, I just never
really liked this flavor.
It's just too heavy on the tomato side.
No. Oh, man, that aftertaste is horrible.
I have nothing nice to
say about this flavor.
Also, just to note, our
standard Lay's chips
come in the ridge style.
We do also sell the flat style,
but that's more of a
special variety of Lay's.
Next, it's West Indies
hot and sweet chili,
formerly Caribbean hot and sweet chili.
That's what I'm talking about.
Get out of here!
And now for the maharaja of Indian Lay's,
magic masala.
If you haven't heard of this,
you must be living under a rock,
because this is the
little emperor of chips.
Commonly known as blue Lay's.
Look at this chip, dude!
Oh, my God.
It's already so spicy.
The reason this chip has
become so popular in India
is because they have
actually managed to capture
the masala of India so well.
And masala, if you're wondering,
is, like, ground-up spices
that are added to every
single dish we eat here.
This is truly magic.
I want to know what they're like.
Joe got himself something.
Oh, man.
And the chip bags in India
are, like, much harder to open.
Oh, man! You guys got
them locked up tight.
Got a rip! OK.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Damn, these are good!
Not too spicy.
Great flavor.
We have so many flavors.
I couldn't get them all for this shoot.
I mean, I'll just start right here.
Barbecue. This is the classic chip.
I think this is more popular
than the classic, to be honest.
The US has, I would say,
at least 10 different variations
of barbecue, possibly more.
So to have just, like,
standard barbecue is
pretty bold move by Lay's.
Salt and vinegar.
[dreamy harp tune]
Love salt and vinegar so much.
I love it so much.
Top chip. Top chip right here.
Love salt and vinegar.
Cheddar and sour cream.
Ha ha ha, limón.
Another favorite. Oh, man.
It seems like lime-flavored
chips would be weird,
or citrusy chips, but ...
so good.
And these are, like, really limey.
All the superfans watching
know I do not like pickles.
No.
Let's kick it up a notch.
Flamin' Hot dill pickle.
And the Flamin' Hot, that font,
that implies that's
Flamin' Hot Cheetos, right?
Mm. Better.
Still not that good.
Last in this group is a chili limón.
Yeah.
These are coming home with me.
Other flavors in this category
that I couldn't get at
the time of filming,
cheddar jalapeño and sweet
Southern heat barbecue.
I was totally able to buy them online.
I get a thing in the mail two days ago
saying the post office
is holding them ransom
and wants 5 more dollars for
postage for me to pick it up.
Not happening.
I will not be intimidated by
the United States post office.
You keep the chips, all right?
Also what I couldn't get
at the time of filming
was honey barbecue,
Chesapeake Bay crab spice,
adobadas, which is a different spicy chip
which is actually very good.
I was bummed I couldn't get those.
And the Doritos Cool Ranch
Lay's, unfortunately.
Let's now talk about two exclusive flavors
that are in both countries,
but slightly different.
We have the sizzlin' hot Lay's
and the American-style cream and onion.
It was previously known as
American sour cream and onion.
It's great. No fuss.
One of my favorite flavors.
It's been there for, like,
over two decades, I feel,
in India, and there's a reason for that.
Ours is just regular sour cream and onion.
And I also got American-style
sour cream and onion
from India.
And then,
one after the other.
The flavor on these are much stronger.
And it even says, "Now with more flavor."
This is more flavor?
I gotta say, I like
these India ones better.
Up next, we have sizzlin' hot.
This is a flavor I've actually never had.
I'm very excited to see how it stacks
compared to magic masala,
which is already pretty spicy.
Whoa.
Yo, look at this chip.
It's literally red.
Not really -- oh.
Nice.
It's not as much a direct
heat as the magic masala.
Hey, this is a nice flavor.
In the US, we have Flamin' Hot flavor.
Now, let me explain.
This is Flamin' Hot kettle chips.
Couldn't get the regular Flamin' Hot.
We'll get into kettle chips later.
It's, like, regular spice.
It has a heat to it
without being too specific.
I think they use these
red chilies right here.
It packs a nice punch
without being too
overwhelming with the flavor.
They're, like, the perfect amount of heat
without getting too overwhelming, so.
OK, so we don't only
have ridge-style chips,
we also have some flat ones.
In fact, they're called wafer style,
which I think is pretty much
your classic style of Lay's.
The first flavor is salt with pepper.
Not salt and pepper.
Don't you dare say that.
It's very nice. I should
buy these more often.
I've never tried these
before. Very good job.
OK, on to the next wafer-style chip.
We have sun-dried chili.
Mm! I love sun-dried anything.
Beam that sun ray onto any
vegetable. I will eat it.
Oh, damn.
This is really good.
They smashed it with this one.
Got a proper kick as well.
Ooh!
It's really yum.
And one of the most beautiful
sights you'll see in India
is people sun-drying their
own chilies on their roofs,
porches, wherever.
Biryanis, curries, they
all use sun-dried chili.
And this chip's packet really
has nailed this flavor.
Maybe my favorite, kettle cooked.
We already saw the
Flamin' Hot kettle cooked.
These are thicker chip.
They transport a lot better, obviously.
There are not as many broken.
It's got more of, like, a potato
taste to it, a potato snap.
It's like ...
I love kettle chips.
Sea salt, cracked pepper.
These are so good.
Mm. Yeah!
It's like ...
booyah!
[grunts]
Sea salt and vinegar.
This ain't your pond salt.
This ain't your lake salt.
This certainly is not your fjord salt.
Why is salt and vinegar so good?
Attention, everyone,
my favorite kettle chip is
about to be eaten by me.
The jalapeño kettle chips.
I'm not going to talk about Miss Vickie's
because this isn't a Miss Vickie's video.
And I hate to say it.
These might be better.
They've got the jalapeño flavor in there.
It's not too spicy,
so you can really chow down on these.
Moving on, unfortunately,
to something that I kind of can't stand,
are baked. Wah-wah.
You can get them in original
and you can get them in barbecue.
Like eating cardboard.
Lay's has something called
the Better for You series.
So we have these, and then
lightly salted barbecue,
lightly salted wavy.
I mean, I want the salt,
but, like, how much ... ?
This is what paper tastes like.
We got simply sea salt thick cut.
And you can also get the
simply barbecue thick cut.
They have something called
layers, which are these guys.
Bite-size layers, crispy
layers, tasty layers.
You can get them in three
cheese, sour cream and onion.
I've never seen these
before in my entire life.
Oh, the bag stinks!
Oh, these are really bad.
These are terrible.
Whoa, these are real chemically tasting.
Oh, my God, these taste
like they were poisoned.
And now for our next
range of exclusive chips,
we have Lay's Maxx.
That's Maxx with two X's.
Why the two X's? That's like
saying it's more better.
I have not seen or tasted these before.
Starting with macho chili flavor.
It is kind of ridged, but
I would say it's more wavy.
I wouldn't say it's super spicy.
I kind of like that this one doesn't leave
that burning sensation in your throat.
It's really nice.
Yeah. I don't know about the branding,
but I really like this flavor.
Next flavor, peppery cheddar.
Whoa. All sorts of stuff happening here.
There's, like, some mint to it.
Oh, you know what this tastes like?
This tastes like malai tikka,
like chicken malai tikka
dipped in pudina chutney.
This is very unique.
Our next flavor is sizzling barbecue.
Oh, the reason this is called Lay's Maxx,
it's because it has
max crunch, max flavor,
and max taste.
And I can wholeheartedly say
both of these have delivered.
Mm. It even smells
strongly of barbecue, so.
These work. They're great.
More fun chip styles.
I think we can call these the India style,
but we also call them the wavy style.
They are wavy, hence the name.
And you can get them in
original, reduced fat,
honey barbecue, ranch,
and you can also get
them in salt and pepper,
lightly salted,
fat, low fat, if I
didn't say that already.
The waves are, like, wider.
You guys have, like,
really condensed waves.
Lay's apparently wanted to
answer the age-old question,
how can we copy something popular
and make it much, much worse?
And Stax were invented.
You guys know what Pringles are, right?
Of course you do. Well.
[chip pieces rattling] Hear that?
"We'll put them in a tube.
They won't break as easily."
Right? [chip pieces rattling]
Holy f---.
Look at this.
Then what was the point of
putting it in this tube?
I hate this so much.
But to really prove my point,
yo, dog, look what I got.
By the way, paper too. Excellent idea,
Dave Pringle, whatever your name is.
F--- Stax.
And now to our final set of exclusives,
the gourmet collection.
I've had a lot of gourmet food in my life,
and I've very rarely been
actually impressed with the food.
Vintage cheese and paprika!
Vintage cheese and paprika.
Oh.
If I had tasted this chip
without any of the fancy packaging,
I don't think gourmet is the first word
that would come to my head.
Thai sweet chili gourmet.
This literally tastes like
the West Indies hot and chili,
but on a flat chip.
So gourmet is just packaging.
That's what we've learned
from this experiment
with these two chips.
Skippable.
In addition to that, we
also have Lay's Poppables.
Poppables come in sea salt and vinegar --
oh, Julius Pringle! That
was his name. Not Dave.
They also have Poppables
sea salt and vinegar,
Poppables sea salt,
Poppable white cheddar,
and Poppable honey barbecue.
OK, I don't want to eat all these.
What's the cereal that looks like this?
Is it Chex?
If you got these on accident, eat them,
but I wouldn't reach for these
over regular potato chips.
Here in India, our Lay's chips
packets come in five sizes.
There's 30 grams, 50 grams,
73 grams, 104 grams,
and 174 grams.
The big boy. The party pack.
I feel like I could eat
this whole thing on my own,
to be honest.
In the US, our Lay's chips
come in six variety of sizes.
All the way down here, got a 28-gram bag,
which comes in the multipack.
Next up, 74.4-gram bag.
In the middle here, there's
also an elusive 78-gram bag.
Look, I saw it on Target.com
and Walmart.com. It exists.
It just wasn't available
anywhere in Southern California.
I looked, OK?
One step up, we have what I think
is the classic grocery-store bag,
226 gram, aka the 8-ounce bag.
You've seen it a million
times. This is the one.
Right next to that one
is the family-sized bag,
which I also couldn't get ahold of.
297.6-gram bag.
I couldn't find it because
the American family is dead.
But what is alive and well is,
of course, our biggest size,
the party size, 368 grams.
All you family-less partyers,
Lay's has you covered.
That means that the biggest bag in the US
is this much larger than
the biggest bag in India.
But wait, there's more,
or less, depending on
the packet that you get,
because according to Amazon,
the weights of these
different packets might vary.
So they're given a weight range.
The biggest weight difference
is in our largest pack
of 174 to 190 grams, which
is a difference of 16 grams.
So let's see how much
we get in one packet.
Ooh!
175 grams, one gram extra
from what is advertised,
which is, I'll take it.
So let me show you what 16
grams of chips looks like,
so you can see what you're
potentially missing out on.
It doesn't seem like a
lot, but I think that's
quite a substantial amount of
chips you're missing out on.
To be fair, they did write
174 grams only on the pack.
In the US, our flavor bags weigh less
than the original-flavor bag.
Take this barbecue-flavored Lay's bag.
It weighs 7.75 ounces, or 7 ¾ ounces.
Yuelei, can we get in there?
You see that? Thank you.
Compared to the 8 ounce you
get with the original bag.
OK. Same price, less product.
Now, Harry did research on that episode,
so take it away, Harry.
What? No, do your own research.
According to Harry's research
from the last Lay's episode,
back in 2014, PepsiCo claimed
the reason that there is
a slightly higher price per
ounce for flavored chips
is the added seasoning.
So then, Lay's,
can you explain to me why
this lightly salted bag
gives you fewer chips
than the original bag?
It's more money but less salt, eh, Lay's?
Check it out.
The lightly salted, so
less salted than this,
also 7 ¾.
While we're exposing potential Lay's lies,
this 28-gram bag in the US
supposedly contains 15 chips,
according to Lay's website.
Let's see how accurate this is.
And I'm going to count all the
chips in this 30-gram packet
to see how many we have.
I mean, it doesn't contain one whole chip.
One.
12, 13.
I mean, if we're doing it
by chip-related piles ...
six, 12, eight?
Close to 18 chips per bag.
Huh. All right, I'll concede.
Cool, so that's 24 chips.
I would say, realistically,
this is, like, 20 chips
that have been broken
into many other pieces.
But let's be real, they
could've fit a lot more chips
into this packet.
And Lay's is notorious
for filling it with air.
It's actually nitrogen gas,
which helps preserve the chips
and also acts as a cushion
to stop them from getting
smashed in transit.
I mean ...
What would it have been
like without the cushion?
This whole bag would've
been dust, apparently.
But what is the
air-to-chip ratio, you ask?
Let's find out in a new
segment I like to call
the Ar-chip-medes principle.
Can I just say, this is
one of the weirdest things
I've done in my life.
A generous 55 ml of chips in this packet.
Now let's measure how
much the packet itself
can hold in volume.
Score!
Ooh, this smells so bad.
900 ml.
That's 845 ml of chips
that we could have had, Lay's.
I feel cheated.
I think to make it more
accurate, let's do four.
And then we'll fill this guy up,
and then we'll divide by four,
and that would give us
the average of those.
Does that make sense?
Dust.
Uh-huh, all right.
Oh, man. All right.
Can I please have the scientific
chip-crunching nunchucks?
Throw them!
Ah! Whoa!
Look out, chips.
Pow. Pow. Pow.
2.75 fluid ounces per bag.
Now that's science you can use.
So, now we're going to
fill this with water.
Ugh.
The whole thing's 20, which is about 2.75.
17.25 units of whatever.
Cubic fluid ounces?
Even more interesting air information.
Because of India's varied geography,
the amount of air that's
packed into these packets
is different for different altitudes.
For example, in cities of higher altitude,
like Leh in the Himalayas,
there is the risk of
these packets exploding
due to the low atmospheric pressure.
And so, when they're sent there,
they're sent with no air
at all inside of them.
And so they run the risk of
being crushed in transport,
so they have to be taken as
delicately as a crate of eggs.
But what about price?
This is our largest chips
packet, the 174 grams.
And on Swiggy and Amazon, this
sells for about 78 rupees,
which is about a dollar right now.
And that equals ...
rupees 0.44 per gram.
About $0.005.
And, yes, I did all of that
math and conversion in my head.
Here in the US, if we break it down
starting with this big bag,
the 226.8 gram, aka 8-ounce, bag,
it's $3.99 at Target,
or 316.58 rupees.
Yes, it's a bigger bag, I know.
So breaking it down per gram,
we found that in the US,
the cost is a 260%
increase compared to India.
While we do enjoy our Lay's chips,
we also have a giant chip
culture here in India.
In fact, these are called hot chips,
and they're sold all across India
at stalls called hot-chip stalls,
where, basically, they
have a giant frying pan,
and they cut the potato in front of you
to these thin slices and fry it
and give it to you nice,
hot-hot, fresh-fresh.
And so, for 174 grams,
which is the same as this,
you're paying rupees 45
for a lot fresher chips.
So as you can see, Lay's
is competing against
a giant chip market here in India
and doing pretty well, I would say.
Now for the burning question.
Are there any questionable ingredients
that are in your Lay's chips
that you need to watch out for?
Fret not, because Joe and I
have found them out for you.
As far as the basic salted version goes,
you're totally fine.
Both in India and the US,
they're made of potatoes,
vegetable oil, salt.
Warning! Warning alert!
Here in India, some of our flavors
have an ingredient called
potassium chloride.
In regular doses, this is completely safe,
and it's a low-sodium alternative to salt.
However, it's also one of
the three ingredients used
in the three-drug cocktail
for lethal injections.
Too much potassium chloride
will cause irregular heartbeats,
and, boom, your heart will stop.
So if you've been thinking
of doing a Lay's mukbang,
be careful.
We don't have any of that in the US Lay's,
but we do have food coloring,
caramel color in our barbecue
and honey-barbecue chips.
Certain types of caramel
color can contain a byproduct
called 4-meI.
Studies found that it caused
cancer in rats and mice,
leading campaigns in support
of banning it from foods.
Give me that dancing rat!
All right. The FDA was
like, "Meh, it's fine.
Humans don't come close
to the level of exposure
that caused the rat tumors."
But that didn't stop
the state of California
adding it to its Proposition
65 list of chemicals, quote,
"known to the state of
California to cause cancer
or reproductive toxicity," end quote. Oof.
Another ingredient found
in several varieties
of Lay's chips here in
India is disodium glutamate,
aka flavor enhancer 69.
No, not 69.
Flavor enhancer 627.
But basically, it's used alongside MSG
to enhance the flavor of the chips.
Both the Food and Drug Administration,
or the FDA, in the United States,
and the European Food Safety
Authority, or the EFSA,
consider disodium glutamate safe.
But it's not recommended
for babies, children,
pregnant women, and lactating mothers,
and also should be avoided by asthmatics
or people suffering from gout.
MSG, if you're wondering,
is the commonly misunderstood ingredient
known as monosodium glutamate
which is added to a lot of Asian cuisine
and gives it that umami flavor.
In 2019, Lay's sued a
bunch of Indian farmers
for growing a certain variety
of potato, FC5 variety,
saying it has a patent on that variety.
This type of potato is
ideal for snack chips,
as it has a lower moisture content.
But strike one up for the little guy.
Farmers'-rights activists
petitioned to the
Protection of Plant Varieties
and Farmers' Rights Authority,
and it agreed.
PepsiCo, Lay's, cannot claim
a patent over a seed variety.
It was revoked immediately,
and the Indian potato
farmers are now flush
with low-moisture-potato money.
Let's go!
So, which country has
the unhealthiest chips?
Let's compare the classics first.
A 28-gram bag of classic Lay's in the US
contains 160 calories,
10 grams of total fat,
1.5 grams of saturated
fat, 15 grams of carbs,
and 170 milligrams of sodium.
OK, so our Lay's nutrition
is per 100 grams.
So I did a little bit of math
to compare it to the US 28 grams.
Actually, Joe did the math.
So if the math is wrong, blame Joe.
OK, so we have 154.8 calories,
total fat, 9.8 grams,
of which saturates are 3.7 grams,
carbs are 14.7 grams,
and sodium, 142.8 milligrams.
Wow, that was pretty close, actually.
We're under the US in every metric
except for saturated fats,
where we are over 164%.
And I think that's because
we use palm-olein oil
to fry our chips, and it's
very high in saturated fats,
unlike the US vegetable oil.
What about the least-healthiest
chip in each country?
Over here, there are a lot of them
that are tied to 160
calories per 28-gram bag.
Show list.
But we did find that the 160-calorie chips
with the highest fat content are these.
No!
The cheddar and sour
cream, I love these guys.
Making them the least healthy.
If I did have a bag that small,
it would contain all of this.
And here in India, our
highest-calorific chip is
classic salted.
How lame.
How is this the most calorific
chip we sell here, Lay's?
If I had to run an extra mile,
it wouldn't be for classic salted.
So you know what the next
most-calorific chip is?
Magic masala, baby.
Blue Lay's.
We had to end with this one.
Super calorific.
I don't know why I'm
proud of that, but good.
Great to know that this
is and forever will be
the maharaja of Lay's.
In the interest of science,
I will taste this liquid.
If I do this,
make sure to subscribe to
the Food Insider channel.
I never thought you could
drink a fart until today.
That was quite ...
it was like potato water
with a hint of salt.